yeah okay we carry feet zip it into feet
I know patience is the key put it out on
my ship for free this is t we carry feet
Michael make them good morning I am
ready to rock n roll good morning
everybody good morning Dustin good
morning all the people in the chats joel
with growing design thank you for
joining us
jokes on the world - thank you for being
here thanks for everybody on on YouTube
Facebook Twitter I see all of you guys
in here and gals Virginia Fernando good
morning let's get into the show
yesterday was a big one let's get right
into it
good morning good morning what's up good
morning what's up my good basically ask
you because I know that used to work
with your dad and we're brothers and we
work together so I wanted to know if you
had any like tips for working with
family yeah
and I worked with my brother and when we
started being or media and my brother
and I work together on being a sports so
look I'll smash it I think the biggest
thing that people make the mistake with
family businesses is a lot of things
actually first of all it if you're
capable of loving each other and more
than the money and the fame and the
respect that will always play out I
genuinely believe that that above
everything else like just truly valuing
the relationships with my brother and
dad like more than the money and the and
the accolades really really mattered
then the other thing is over
communicating to each other about
dollars and the like kind of respect I
think one of the reasons that one of the
reasons that my brother and I worked so
well together was my brother was more
confident and more comfortable with me
being the front man and getting the
credit and he and and he valued the
dollars you know not more but like he
was fine with that and for me I value
the dollars less than being
the guy right I want to be the guy with
my dad we we had more of that friction
point of like who's the guy and that
made it more difficult but but still we
were kind of able to overcome you know
the friction this is just ego and
respect and money those are the two
places and that's why it's so hard
most people actually care about money
and get into fights over it or they
actually care about like who like who
actually why did you sell all that
merchandise was that Sebastian was at
Auburn there's that ego and that and
that and then there's the legacy of it
and then you know just it's it's
balancing humility and wanting credit
you know there's just a lot of like real
emotions you know what I mean
decision-making is really tough because
we both have valid points and I never
would say this fashions wrong anything
but I would say that when I come up with
like my point or my perspective and he
comes up with his perspective it's
really tough to balance out each other
and you know you know what's really
worked for both of my family businesses
dividing and conquering because you
can't have two cooks in the kitchen
cuz to your point they're like it's not
that you think Sebastian's wrong it's
that by you saying it should be red and
him saying it should be blue just in
that small thing you know when you're
when you're passionate about your thing
you want to see your thing come to life
it's not even about being right or wrong
it's not seeing it come to life the way
you envisioned it in your brain I really
I really mean this like I think where
people get caught is they try to both do
the same thing and I think dividing and
conquering matters like like when you
have two cooks in the kitchen you have
no cooks in the kitchen just friction so
so for example just because you guys are
wearing it if you're doing merch I would
just look if I was like the third
brother be like hey here's this right if
I was the third older brother here's the
strategy we're gonna make nine pieces of
merch and everybody makes their own
three pieces and who gives a [ __ ] if the
fonts are different and who gives a [ __ ]
if like you know you know what I mean
you see you know sometimes because that
will work better you know because then
merit can breathe versus it being
convoluted and what ends up happening
when it doesn't work
or what it does work you know when it
doesn't work you're doing this you like
see it was your [ __ ] live you know
even though both of your DNA's in it and
when it does work even though it's
blended then both are saying this and
you get into that friction point and
that's why I think dividing and
conquering might really matters well
joint decisions are impossible for a
business okay then you know like back to
like sports there's you don't have two
quarterbacks yeah you have two
quarterbacks but once on the bench
they're not both out there grabbing the
ball same with businesslike
there is no co-ceo it doesn't work true
but what you could do is if your
partner's is divide and conquer and
literally you know with one thing you
know in every you almost want to write
down every task and then pick one person
to be one a and one person to be one B
okay and what that meet you know agent I
had a really good rule which was if if
we actually actually couldn't get to a
joint decision through a conversation I
would make the final call
cuz I was a CEO you know like that was
that was basically the punchline and and
that really worked and you know and and
he was great at like kind of you know
sticking to that and so you know I think
that um you know with my dad I really
let him work on the finances and I kind
of operated but he it was his business
and he was used to operating and so when
he would kind of try to make a joint
decision or or a post decision or just
my decision that's when a lot of
friction happen especially with when you
have got employees underneath you you
know my whole life you know
in essence I mean still to this day
basically every professional day of my
life I've been in that place and I'll be
honest with you like when I'm most by
myself is when it's most enjoyable no I
mean what I mean by that is you know in
the years where my dad was really
letting me run the business it was like
great you know Boehner was really easy
AJ really gave me that spot but even
after he left and went to run dator
sports it was even better
you know just it's it's hard when you're
when
to share the ball and it's not because
you're greedy or you're mean or you want
your you're selfish it's that you know
decisions drive a business and and I
have enormous conviction and can make my
decisions very quickly and I struggle
with people that don't have that clarity
or like you know whether you know and
anybody who doesn't agree you know I
don't have clarity on other people's
decisions either
I think it's dividing conquer conquer
like what's been the biggest friction
point for you to like what's been the
biggest fight that you've had or about
what it's mainly when we just have two
different opinions or something but um
we've definitely learned from before a
lot of different ways to UM to work
together and stuff I mean obviously we
still go through our struggles and with
a horse the most part everything's been
way better than before do you guys have
a good sense of where you are if I said
to both of you between money and like
the credit where do you guys sit like
it's Oliver special if I asked you
there's a hundred percent for you for
you money credit
where are you percentage-wise credit but
but real quick real quick on that it's
not as simple as that so for example
when you say credit money you might be
70/30 and he might be thirty seventy and
in that is the actual unlock to your
happiness cuz you're not a hundred zero
and he's not a zero hundred ya know once
you understand that it really helps but
I'm telling you by a country mile the
number one piece of advice I have is
don't be in a position where you have to
make joint decisions dividing conquer as
much as you can and where you have to
make joint decisions see if you can do
both okay sounds like that sounds cool
like that you see what I mean because
yes it's the more separated you are the
more together you'll be right like it
through like hey we want to make this
piece of content just make both of your
[ __ ] pieces of content like literally
even if they're similar
I got you I got you good good luck guys
hey what's up what's up yeah I'm back
again thank you for doing this super
happy to be here so I'm gonna go
straight to the point I wanted to hear
your take on quantity versus quality of
content for consistency purposes so my
question is is a lot of average content
better than great content yes with a
lower consistency okay here's why who
gets to decide that it's average richer
all right
true true answer the question I mean
it's this me it's only me who controls
like the contest that's it that's it
that's where you have it mixed up that's
why I'm so excited that's why I wanted
to answer it okay you know you don't get
to decide the audience gets to decide
okay and you're gonna say no for the
audience too often okay creators artists
say no for the audience without the
audience having a look that's true the
end that's why this is such an easy
question for me
cool it's an easy question
it's just insecurity about the content
you know people use perfection as a
disguise to not put out it's actually
being a cliche artist and worrying about
what people think and having some sort
of ideology in your own head or just
judging your own self that's why I want
to push everybody to put things out
because they will learn from what the
audience likes instead of playing the
game of life in their own head okay true
yeah because I always try to do them you
know as you advocate us to do two three
pulses daily so I try to onto that flow
but I find it difficult sometimes
because I want to do above-average
packaging but you are making that up in
your own mind okay
like that's my concern my concern is
that you've got I don't know if you even
know yet if you haven't put out a
hundred things you don't even
no you know you're below average might
be above average hmm
you just might be that talented or you
may put out something that's below
average but you read the comments and
you get an insight which makes your next
piece of content way better yeah yeah
you're people do not most people do not
respect the audience okay it's a very
interesting insight like I would argue
that what really works for me is I
overly respect the audience all I'm
doing is like looking at the comments
right now while I'm on with you from
Anton Goodwin and Kareem al Rasheed II
and Sam Reed and Mark Martinez I'm
watching mm-hmm even when I'm creating
okay they're always right we're never
right okay and like we might have been
right and then it plays out but we don't
know if we're right or wrong until it
goes out sure and no content ruins you
people like oh if I put this out people
don't think I'm wack and then I have no
shot just doesn't work that way you know
which wack [ __ ] songs the Beatles put
out more than people realize like that
right no it's a it's a liberator yeah
yeah it makes me realize that I can do
yeah so after like dwell on little
things and just go ahead and and post it
you also don't know you post it to see
if you're right like I put it like this
is gonna suck and it sucks something
yeah I know my [ __ ] like when I write up
wine text you know and I write it
sometimes I grew this is fires gonna
sell out a minute sometimes and then you
know and then when it doesn't do well
I'm like whoo I'm on my [ __ ] I was right
it was air sometimes like a ship flies
out in an hour all sold out and I'm like
hmm
okay that taught me there you know you
gotta learn mm-hmm okay cool
I have a one quick question you always
say also to be giving to do jobs jobs
jobs and I wanted to see with you does
it make sense to like provide like I'm a
producer DJ sound engineer does it make
sense to provide my my crew
patience two people who I still got
emails maybe even if we don't
necessarily still talk it could be
people who work with like maybe the
Rihanna's or other street dancers and
stuff like that but just to reach time
I'd be like hey I got this I was
thinking about you I think this makes
sense or that's yes but you know that
they're doing more for you than you're
doing for them okay okay when you're
Rihanna if they're putting in your
[ __ ] you know if they're taking your
productions that's huge for you what
would be better in my opinion is to go
to SoundCloud or Instagram or tik-tok
and find people that are merging that
really need it then you're really giving
yes when you're giving to Rihanna or
beyoncé there you're not giving they're
putting you on okay okay okay
I get that all right thank you yeah
people often want to give to people that
when they receive it it actually is more
valuable to you people want to give me
things all the time you know but the
reality gotta be I made this song for
you for your tea with Gary B but like
you know the reality is we've had two
theme songs on tea with Gary B the
second one that's been good but a lot of
people made those things and a lot of
times they're making it for their
benefit so you know and that's great and
sometimes the person will say yes but
please recognize you're not giving
you're asking in that scenario exposure
at that level is worth way more than the
production value of that thing just
always especially in the world whereas
unlimited people offering that
production so keep going
hey Gary hey Gary
are you doing so good super grateful to
be here thank you so much for having us
Thanks
what's cookin so we're here in Westfield
we're not too far from you mmm
super close yes sir yes sir super
grateful and so Pee Wee's been listened
to for a while I jumped on started
listening to you back in December and
got to say that you know what you guys
what you say it works so I started
everything we have our podcast adjacent
pili project we've had some great guests
come on by just DM in them through
Instagram and all a sudden to replying
just shocking people I had to get them
they go Gary Vee said DM oh my god try
that oh yeah people come on so our goal
this year was we were working to get
really more live speaking going that's
gonna now gets night on for a long time
where you say well start a live show to
somebody about a week ago so we started
a live show every day at noon and so a
second cup of coffee with Jason and fili
live and uh that's been going well
across our platforms were getting good
like private feedback from people like
people when I greet you on the sidelines
but we're we're not finding a way to get
like active engagement of platforms and
I are striving you're getting private
messages at a high level but you're not
getting as many comments and likes and
shares on the actual content correct
which which what do you want the most of
let's go very technical here to bring
people value we don't say engagement in
order on which platform and then before
we go into that what's the content that
you're talking about so our podcast is
about providing fulfillment really just
pushing to prove that we can improve
mental fortitude grow wealth and improve
health and as a foundation in real
estate we are we are large multifamily
providers understood so are you getting
a lot of private things that are that
are just because people are getting into
a mindset thing and they're being honest
with you on DM that they may feel
uncomfortable in the comments section or
asking you more direct questions
financially of how to become a
multi-family kind of executor like
you're just finding more in that realm I
get a lot in the fitness side I might do
a lot of crazy challenges on the fitness
side so I'm running like 465 miles this
month and a lot of people reach out from
that and like their app running engine
that I'm sorry privately or privately
yeah you know it's funny I get way more
private messages than I get him with my
engagement and I get a shitload of
engagement it just means I get a
fuckload of you know private messages
but you know let's break this down if I
went very literal because I know I don't
do this often so I think this will help
a lot of people and you guys have
clearly shown to me that you've listened
to tactics which have brought you
benefit so I really want to go tactical
what when you say engagement which
platform and what action sure so
Facebook in YouTube would be the prime
to that we try and build that further
okay and what n are you looking for are
you saying when you say engagement are
you looking for comments and likes or if
you're talking about these two platforms
are you talking about more subscribers
so YouTube would be subscribers Facebook
would be engagement to make sure that
we're providing content that's bit of
benefiting the listeners because right
now we're getting the private feedback
where are but we're not getting on the
platform so we're not sure if our
content is giving the framework if sure
you you're getting the feedback yeah
just not you yeah Jason you said to me
you're looking for the feedback to make
sure that you're providing the right
value but you are getting the feedback
you're actually saying which is very
fine no problem at all hey we'd like to
get more of it publicly because that in
itself helps us more more people see it
it does momentum so you're not looking
to help them you looking to help
yourself and there's nothing wrong with
that but but I want to break it down
right yeah you know for me for me I'm
able to really create more content seven
out of ten times because the private
message is more than the comments
because people will go a level deeper
private there's something there
rich kids are sad I need to talk about
entitlement you know like that that's me
nobody's leaving a comment like Gary
that's me I'm a rich kid I'm piece of
[ __ ] I take all my money from my parents
but I'm a pretend I own it I suck like
that people don't do that they are they
do it in DM right and so I think that
what you're talking about a little bit
more is things that benefit you which is
fine more comments more shares more
likes you should I I genuinely believe
it's very hard to be selfless unless you
have a level of selfishness you should
have your own ambitious wants and needs
so it's not that you want more feedback
to make sure you're doing the right
thing because you're getting that it's
that you're trying to grow which is
super fine believe it or not the answer
is really wild
it's called asking so one of the things
that really works is literally asking
like for example even though I can bring
it up a hundred times
none of these [ __ ] are signing up for
wine texts
but when up thank you today but I don't
know if you drink you Noir but today is
a crazy one
so get ready 30 days we got three live
I've got being quiet but I think you
need to ask I think I think you should
make a nice little piece of content at
the end of all your content
it basically says hey it would mean a
lot like you should film something be
like hey we're really hustling out here
it would mean a lot to us if you left a
comment and share this and like them
subscribe like the ask though the right
hook of the jab like most people are
just not asking yeah it's literally just
asking both in video audio written and
visual for yes good amount of content
and so maybe we're missing that just
really the end cap do you know you know
you know what I did with Wine Library TV
that completely exploded it back in a
day what I wanted that I created
something called the question of the day
so like every episode of wine allowed me
to be a thousand of them
you know maybe nine hundred fifty of
them after I invented it was like
alright time for the question a day
which Pinot Noir did you drink in your
you know and then it got people to
practice yeah so you know question a day
or you know I do it still now like tag
one person that you think will get value
out of this yeah it's called the ask
okay got it you know you're providing
value for your audience you're more than
in a position to ask not demand not say
if you don't leave a comment you get
kicked out it's a very simple ask here
we go we got kiddos running live by it
so the world yes a super few changes so
I I don't have any crazy gifts for you
we appreciate your content but I do ask
10 minutes on our podcast somewhere in
the future yes somewhere in the future
I'm internet all because this little
cutie this is baby xyrix perspective
you're welcome see you later see you
Gary thank you big pinot noir today on
wine text very simply simple ask based
on that
let's go meta if you buy wine if you buy
three bottles of wine a month in any
shape or form Publix
Trader Joe's Costco wine calm like if
you buy three bottles of wine a month
please please please please
stop right now go to wine texts calm
signup it takes two minutes take a photo
put it on Twitter
let me retweet you that you did it it
would mean a lot to me
let's keep it going hey Gary I've this
is exciting
wow this is huge the n-c-double-a Board
announced it supports a rule change that
would allow student application for
third party endorsement elated and
separate from athletics starting in 21
also supports compensation for other
opportunities in social media Wow Vayner
sports penis sports just cherry can you
hear us
yeah I just want to wasn't sure you know
so I could hear you know breaking news
out of the NC double-a oh okay yeah
about compensating kids that play
collegiate sports which I think will
really change famous sports okay let's
rock and roll
hi Gary always wanted to meet you I'm
probably like everywhere I'm in my life
right now is because of you so I tried a
flat you took action but I appreciate
I'll take the assist all John stuff okay
okay so I tried a Bay flipping like
three times failed every time I tried
Krypto investing and Amazon FBA and now
I have a freelance business and I just
got to quit my job but Walmart three
months ago good for you so my question
is when should I like hire my first
employee because I want to grow beyond
just a one man okay can you afford it
out um I don't know let's define
affording okay as long as you don't
spend money do you have enough money to
get an employee not like full-time
should at least delay at least a little
bit yeah then you should do it okay okay
the sooner you learn what
feels like to employ someone the better
so even if that's somebody for ten hours
a week that's learning's for you that's
why it's awesome if you pay the minimum
wage or something small you're like
snapping people you know we're you know
Jerry you know where people get really
caught they don't pay for they're
willing to pay for college mm-hmm and to
learn but then in real life they're not
willing to pay to actually learn you
paying somebody is gonna teach you how
to be a boss of somebody and it's a much
better than a college diploma that talks
about being the boss of somebody well
that's your not interesting that you say
that please I I did martial arts for 12
years okay and I took minimum wage from
the guy and so I was actually ended up
like losing money because I did pay for
teaching certificates and I did run like
the demo team for a while and teaching
and like planning curriculum and run an
instructor so I kind of understand like
that one thing you said what was it like
three 9s is not as good as like 66's or
something yeah remember that I like yes
I kind of feel smarter I learned that
before you put that out don't worry I'm
not I don't get to make the rules
okay the share my thoughts and things
I've learned like you know don't even
don't put my advice on a pedestal but
you know this know this you hiring
somebody even for ten hours a week is a
monster win okay because if let's just
I'm just gonna use ten bucks an hour
that hundred bucks a week is teaching
you're getting paid to learn to learn
and then if she or he is bringing you
value I mean it's a [ __ ] huge win
people are very confused out here
brother people are willing to pay to
learn through courses and degrees and
schools and then they don't learn by
paying to do things in their actual
business I basically think everything
I'm doing is learning and if I get the
output that I paid for then that's like
the bonus okay I want the context you
want okay I want the reps oh okay that
makes sense to me now all of a sudden
you can see why you would hire somebody
earlier because now it's a different
value proposition than am I gonna get my
return on my money
it doesn't matter if you do now you're
learning something which is gonna help
you long term because you're so young
yeah yeah yeah I'm only 21 baby you are
a super baby yeah okay keep thinking
that way keep thinking like your martial
arts then keep remembering this moment
when we talked investing in something
that brings you learnings is always a
goal is always better especially better
than learning it on paper or from
somebody else you learning it you know
hearing about it ten times is way less
valuable than doing it once okay yeah
cuz I I've kind of been frustrated
lately because I took on like way too
much work yeah man it's time Ella gate
it's you know like the 12 hours a day is
just too much for me right I respected
by the way I love you for saying that
for me it's not because I got some I got
adrenaline in a different way and for
you but seven hours is too much bro
there's no level of money there's no
level of success that is me other than
happiness and balance okay I love you
for that don't think this is why notice
how I said hey when I was listening to
you I was like don't take all my stuff
literal take my macro literal you need
to be happy so six hours is good for you
well great then that's what it's gonna
be that yeah yeah cuz then I did see
that because I I saw like my work when I
was doing you read about six by the way
like lucky guess
because my work I was when I was working
only six a day it was getting done
faster this when I was working 12 I got
this game up his say I want to make sure
you also one thing to look into is how
much do you love what you're doing
versus you think it's making you money
because one thing I noticed is 12 is
easier when you [ __ ] or addicted to
it I agree it's definitely not because I
video at it that's my thing right yeah
it's not a twelve hour a day thing but
it's not a zero either I love it you're
such a great spot at 21 to have that
knowledge to have this framework keep
tasting new different [ __ ] I like where
you don't bro okay I see some people
want to get hired why don't we put your
I'll handle up here people everyone D
I'm Jared if you want to get hired what
are you hiring for um I need a video
editor for right now it's just Instagram
captions helping me spellcheck because I
suck at writing so let Dustin put you in
touch with some of our team we're using
some software too and then you could
have somebody is it rheostat it I think
it is yeah yes host yep and then it's a
I use it does well think this means a
lot to me it's only really am so people
can be um you I do but I don't use it
cuz I don't what about an email good
yeah an email okay what's your email
it's a Pacific Business whitey at
gmail.com do you mean I read in a chat
for does very smart okay Pacific Pacific
Business miss whitey for YouTube at
gmail.com mmm Pacific business whitey at
gmail.com well thank you I'm gonna be
busy reading email today that's okay I
think you are I think you are so what do
you what are you looking hire real quick
it's either either someone to help with
captions or someone to help cut down
gameplay livestreams one of those two
awesome thanks Gary
take it means a lot that isn't happy to
do a brother keep pushing a nice kid
alright let's keep this going
let's keep this going keep it going
hi ina Tasha thank you so much for
having me
can you hear me okay perfectly I am the
child of an immigrant as well and so I
instantly connected with you and your
story and the way you deliver messages
just is exactly how my dad delivers
messages and so you're the way you
deliver everything is perfect so I'll
get into this I'll give you some context
I created and I started out just doing
crafts fairs and I honestly was supposed
to just kind of be like up for fun on
the side hobby extra income type thing
and
and I ended up loving it and I then
hopped on Etsy back in December didn't
really get any traction off Etsy then I
started a tick-tock thanks to you I
started to Chuck and had a video go
viral I'm her piensa City and so I
painted a custom Chiefs jacket and that
video and tick-tock my viral I had like
I'm viral for me I I'm you know by not
not a longshot not you know Charlie or
whoever but I think it got like 40 50
thousand views and I was like whoa and
then Etsy started like changing and I
was like holy cow what the heck just
happened and so what happened is you
started executing the things I talked
about every day 100% yeah I executed
what you said and it did really well and
I need a popping off Etsy because they
take obviously a portion of your fees
and I felt like if I'm driving my own
sales through what you're teaching me to
do why should I give them a portion of
my money so I ended up creating my own
website things were a little slow at
first and then I had another video go
viral Amelia I think one point four
million views which was insane again my
website to change changing and then the
following week shonda rhimes ended up
sharing one of my art pieces on her
Instagram feed and so then it was like
again I'm like her just like you had
instructed people to do I tagged her it
was a Grey's Anatomy same post tagged
her she reposted it and it was insane so
off of that this is obviously very new
to me I have had several like
influencers lifestyle bloggers message
me wanting to get like some free product
a free jacket free stickers free art all
the stuff that I make is there a secret
free stickers free stickers excites me
what was that free stickers excites me
that's low cost for you for good
exclusion yeah yeah three stickers yes
three [ __ ] jackets mmm only if they
promise to post it and they're real big
okay
secret math there's no formula you have
to go on intuition you should audit them
see how engaged their audience really is
you know maybe FaceTime them for two
minutes maybe you can get a real
connection free stickers all day okay
it's just cheap they put on their laptop
or they share it like even if they don't
share it it's let them have it around
their life there there are people that
have influence you know but but um it's
just it's just value exchange you know
like if you decide somebody's worth a
free jacket and that's right for you
then do that to influence marketing will
work for you it's not a requirement but
if you have something is low-cost as
free stickers I'm really into that okay
okay
yeah stickers and my art friends those
are you know you know what you need to
do though when you send something to
somebody and nothing good happens you
can't dwell you have to look at it at
the macro okay it's kind of like the tip
top viral posts you know if you gave up
after the first nine that only got 12
you know views and said Gary's an idiot
you would have never gotten to the time
when the video went viral same with
influencers if you give up after like
you're like [ __ ] Sarah what a [ __ ]
her you know she didn't you know like if
you knew that you're finished you need
to be like Sarah sucked rick suck johnny
suck jenna suck
Stevie sucked Ricky stuck oh my god a
man that changed my life okay got it
yeah because I did people get emotional
people get emotional get emotional
they're like oh [ __ ] Sally ripped me
off all her followers are fake I bet you
know like like even if they posted and
nothing good happened you're like [ __ ]
people get emotional there's no there's
no [ __ ] crying or emotion business
yeah yeah and I did I had like 12 videos
that got literally eight views so if I
had stopped I wouldn't have had any
success that's right okay my another
quick question so I had had an idea to
do Instagram lives with my followers one
on one basically like this but teaching
them digital art on their iPads and I
have a business mentor and they kind of
kiboshed it they're like no you need a
charge you need to charge for that like
doing maybe like a 20 to 30 minute
session you are your business mentor is
a salesperson
okay I am a marketer and Brander mm-hmm
I don't agree and I know you know that I
don't agree yeah yeah oh I knew
instantly I was like Gary's not gonna
agree and I don't necessarily agree but
my goodness you want two to one yeah
true
my other question though is there ever a
time or horse yeah that I can charge for
that or yes when you desperately need to
okay you know what the goal is though
what's that yeah by the way you know
what's gonna happen you're gonna build a
[ __ ] community that's gonna buy you
another [ __ ] okay you're business
mentors transactional okay
you're business mentors 101 okay if
you're business mentors getting paid you
may want to reconsider it okay all right
yeah I mean I I listen to your podcast
24/7 and I I implement and I've turned
so many other people onto it too and
implemented it and good thing you've
implemented my free advice and a lot of
good things have happened yeah you're
paying for that advice I'd like to see
what the ROI of that is yeah yeah very
true and I knew instantly I think you
need to I think you need to say I think
you need to write a nice email that says
we no longer work together
that's my intuition I could be wrong
maybe she or he's bringing a lot of
value but but if if if I heard
everything you just said which is you're
selling things from exposure
I would never charge transactional $29
for [ __ ] okay all right right on talk
to it thank you so much Gary see ya
business mentors Mike [ __ ] dick
let's keep it going
Devon what's good hey Gary thanks for
having me how you doing
really good hey so before I get to my
question just want to give you a quick
background on where I'm coming from four
years ago I quit my full-time job to
start my own business and I built that
business up for the last three and a
half years and ended up selling it about
six months ago when I started the
business I was just all about speed what
works what doesn't so we did a lot of
like a bee testing we tried direct
marketing direct sales and I have a
sales background we tried yeah variety
of different things and what was it was
a virtual reality events business so we
need b2b events like conferences yeah
things of that nature one of those
things that we did like a be testing for
was just generally social media hi and
say that's probably something stupid to
cut but basically we saw so much success
in other areas that we just decided
social medias not for us right social
media by nature is branding and
marketing and sales and most people are
looking for sales at first it's a
complete ROI math arbitrage it's it's
people build it's the last call you know
the reason I'm different than most
people is I actually know how to build
nike not how to sell 30,000 pairs of
sneakers you know what I mean
yeah no I completely agree I've been
listening to you for three or four years
honestly I started listening great when
I started that job and I keep listening
to you
because I I know social media guy
Szombathely obviously especially in the
long term but what I really like
listening to you about is your passion
your authenticity everything about like
knowing who you are so that's a lot of
what I've been absorbing so I sold my
business about six months ago because I
had more or less like not a change in
passion I was never passionate about
that business but I just needed doing
something just yeah I just I want to
start doing something I was passionate
about and I sold that and now I started
a new business which we just launched a
few weeks ago
it's son protective apparel so I had
changes in my life last year where I got
married so that was a big life change
but then I was also diagnosed with
melanoma skin care
which fortunately was removed but I'm
athletic I did college track and field I
still I'm a CrossFit coach big into the
fitness community I'm always outdoors
working out and there was no shirts that
could actually protect me from UV so
like that was like the market made I
found so I'm launching my own product
there's so there's there's no better
business on earth than when someone
scratches their own edge yeah so it's my
favorite literally my favorite literally
my favorite way of business starts
literally my favorite number one number
one yeah I mean that's a big reason I
started it because of listening to your
content and hearing that over and over
and over it's like what is my need what
what exists in the marketplace or what
doesn't exist in the marketplace that I
can fill that need so yeah I jumped in
started it so I have a fresh slate again
didn't do any social media last business
personally I do little to no like social
media I don't have like a personal brand
it's really just a way for like I use
social media strategically to reach out
decision-makers on Instagram use that
messaging sphere use Twitter like but I
don't have any personal preference yeah
and what one thing I'm worried about if
you're using that are using it from your
personal account or your brand's account
so I've in the past I've used it from my
brand's account you know some of the
things that you need to keep in mind is
how good that brand or the person shows
up is a big factor in the conversion
about outreach yeah you know like like
like a highly attractive person boy or
girl
is more likely to get the person they're
courting when they're out that they
think is cuter than one that's not say
what social if your [ __ ] is good on
social when you reach out good things
happen at a higher percentage so one
thing to think because you got sale your
salesman which I love I am too I get it
so you've got that part down what I you
know what's super important what and you
could be very effective with this like
when you start reaching out to
influencers or other people if your
brand's showing up proper when they look
at who DM them they're more likely to do
something with you at a better cost
whether that's free or a discount if you
look like [ __ ] or if you're not playing
the game right they're gonna
twice you can see how the economics
amortize out very quickly on just III
sure because your sales brain you
already can see why I just gave you a
very good reason that your Instagram and
Pinterest and tic-tac like they need to
look proper just on the ARB on the
transactional influencer marketing play
yes that's actually ultimately the
question I had for you so basically I
have two blank slates I have my business
at my personal I want well I want to
deliver it all content so just start
both so it's more effective to do four
hours every single day of my business or
like two and two if I only have let's
say I only have four hours is why can I
help that part I don't know that part
it could change day by day but yeah I'm
starting a new apparel business I mean
just the process of getting operations
set up sales I see I see you're talking
about four hours of marketing not four
hours a 44 hours available to dedicate
to marketing that's amazing first of all
that's amazing so you what you went from
putting me in a bad mood to in a great
you know what I would do not overthink
it you know go with the flow being a
personal brand is tricky it might not be
in your DNA you might be self-conscious
you're like what do I [ __ ] say you
know please look into the you know the
content pyramid I put out and watch the
video of like a document don't create
like get that into your brain here's the
answer one day 30 minutes personal brand
three-and-a-half hours brand one day you
know five days in a row four hours
personal brand then for two-and-a-half
people think there's a blueprint there
isn't it's a net-net game I'm I'm not
you know I want you to taste both at
enough scale that wanted to emerge but
look a cancer survivor is inspirational
period that is an emotionally like you
know like [ __ ] man you know and you can
help a lot of people [ __ ] selling [ __ ]
like you're gonna help some kids yeah
right you're gonna start you off with 16
year old you know it is bigger than you
so like you've got to do the personal
brand but the apparel brand will will be
able to scale you when you hire two
people so the answer is both both both
both both
and don't over judge yourself on the
strategy upfront there is no right
answer it's just gonna just let it flow
whatever your [ __ ] feeling let it
flow and when you don't feel it just
like you didn't feel the [ __ ] BR
business anymore switch it so I get a
little burnt out of doing personal [ __ ]
you go hard boom boom boom you know
that's why I love having a ton of [ __ ]
sometimes I'm flowing on empathy whines
sometimes I've flown in white X
sometimes I flow and Boehner and then
Vayner X has like [ __ ] lunch Manor
Commerce this like you know I can't I
can't stop launching businesses because
I need I need flow yeah Congrats on
Boehner Comics by the way thank you all
right bro what's you why I appreciate it
take your device blow blow blow blow
it's really cool really cool business I
like what he's going I'm really rooting
for him and his Saints signed JaJuan
Johnson one of our Boehner sports most
exciting rookies this year so Dustin UK
over there little slow on the trigger
well I always like to wait till you
finish your sentence thank you sir thank
you hi hi Marian I met you in 2009 and I
apologize cuz it took me way too long to
listen to you well listen I'm glad
you're here
thank you so I've been going through jab
jab jab right hook on the southpaw so I
guess for me it's related and I
understand on page 13 you talk about
that magic blueprint that everybody
wants to know when it's time for the
right hook and I understand that that
doesn't exist so my question is what are
the indicators that you look for of
knowing when it's time to throw that
hook it's less about the indicators from
the audience it's more about the
indicators in my real life like when
empathy wines was done being made and it
was time to sell it was time to throw
the right hook and announce it you know
when wine text was invented then went
three months and I felt it was perfected
then it was the time to right hook
it's less about you feel like your
audience is there it's more about the
necessity to throw the right hook
there's never a bad time to throw a
right hook
there's I of a preference that the
longer you can build trust that your
hook will land more likely because most
people and you know this are throwing
right hooks from day one yeah but but I
would say that the indicator to when is
more predicated on the business whether
it's a financial need I mean there's
some people that need to throw right
hooks right now that didn't want to yeah
but but their business is struggling in
a koban world and so I think that um I
think I think the right hook is
predicated more on your business truth
your need for dollars the longer you
don't need dollars just like that young
woman a couple of questions ago if you
don't have to monetize your audience
don't you know if I lost all my
businesses you know maybe tea with Gary
B would just be a subscription business
because I need to feed my family I
prefer but I prefer not to throw the
right hook and when I throw right hooks
I try to make them not direct to what I
do for a living I like that my right
hooks are like sneakers and wine more
than more than pay walls behind content
because I'm established that as a free
part of my life mm-hmm
so I have a brick and mortar and I'm
working on pivoting to your model of
content free content to paid access yes
I love that so do me a favor Marian when
you go to that make sure when you're in
your free world that you're reading
you know just flirting just to the last
part and then you gotta pay what I what
I think it really requires it's kind of
how I think about nonprofit I don't
start businesses that have like if you
buy if you buy empathy we donate five
dollars to you know I don't like mixing
I like doing my thing and then quietly
behind the scenes doing the right thing
in my give back that's I like that
separation similar to the young man that
started this show
divide and conquer you know when people
blend stuff they tend to get caught so
you know if you're a strategy goddess
which I love
you know do me a favor really go really
give everybody your best know this the
information is a commodity there's
nothing I don't say publicly that I say
to my clients
it's the nuances of the deep
and the execution mm-hmm most people
that want to sell content think that
they have to hold something back that
they don't hear in the free part it's
not true you're selling the access the
one on one where I can ask an extra
question when you can ask some education
that's why this has been so powerful in
comparison of my Q&A shows I've had time
to go deeper I was having with thirty
one minutes with a 20 minutes history
with that guy you know like so it's the
depth what that should liberate you to
give better information for free because
you know you're selling access and
nuances not information and understand
yeah the access is where it gets what I
would call into a real custom kind
correct right and you can do custom in a
lot of ways you could have a scaled like
50 person group that all pay one thing
you can that you could have enough
tiered even in the pay part you can have
the fifth you know the up to a hundred
people paying 100 bucks a month and then
you can have the thousands of dollars
thing because it's one-on-one for hours
mmm more access more valuable okay any
other advice about having like a really
big vision because I know you have your
vision about buying the Jets mine's
pretty big go ahead what is it I want to
end violence against women and children
so I think you know I think when you
have such an altruistic you know 20 I
have I have a secret bigger mission the
Jets thing which is I want to reframe
alpha-male success to be around kindness
and empathy
I think hey you have to realize you have
no shot of accomplishing a beauty for
your death when it's that big so when
you're boiling the ocean you need to
enjoy the process and you need to know
that you're just one tiny Block in the
building towards it and you try to try
to be the best possible block you can be
I think when people have big goals they
get crippled by it and then they really
just get into this mucky place so I
think you just need to be practical
about how big of a goal that is and you
need to push hard every day every day
every day I push hard through my private
and public actions to put kindness and
empathy and compassion and sympathy and
warmth on a pedestal and that's all you
can do that was one of my favorite
moments I think it was two weeks ago of
you and your dad where he just grabbed
your face and plan
this kiss on you and I I was just in
tears it was so beautiful to see that
nice is good like we need so much more
light negativity unfortunately is much
louder than positivity and so and so
that's why people are so stressed and
caught up in what social media does
because those should be is just an
exposure an indicator a mirror to who we
actually are doesn't change us it's
exposing us so you know if you have good
in your soul it's I feel like it's a
huge requirement to share it and talk
about it mm-hmm thank you thank you for
eating that kind of emotional range we
need more men like you out there
demonstrating that so thank you for mana
you're welcome take your Mariya bye bye
let's keep this going
Curtis URI URI
I can't good really good this is super
exciting holy [ __ ] um so I'll just give
you a little bit of context and then
I'll ask out like two questions one's a
little bit more heady one's a little bit
more tactical so just to bring some
value and then kind of explain all this
psychic I moved out I [ __ ] I don't
rely on my parents as much anymore
I traded my car and I don't drive like a
fancy car anymore well my dad bought the
car and like you know he kind of values
that stuff and like I understand he
comes from why why did why do you decide
that I was trying to cut costs I'm
trying to like live you know how you're
like live humble yeah why was it did
somebody tell you my content something a
big insecurity I've always had was
relying on my parents right and so we
bought the car it's like [ __ ] like it's
not I didn't do that you know I mean
like it's not I got in so you were
always there mentally you always had a
discomfort with that relationship 100%
keep going yeah and you know I I worked
at like shitty job that you talked about
where I get to have all this time to do
the stuff that I want to do but I get
the job done and you know I live in this
humble apartment and and the biggest
thing is like I stopped valuing
perfection to when I start putting
content out right so if you look at some
of the stuff on my Instagram I'm like
I'm literally in my girlfriend is your
Instagram Kurt underscore DC and so like
like like kickboxing videos and like I'm
literally in my girlfriend's room and
there's like
on the fork I don't give a [ __ ] I
understand love it yeah I'm so far
you're firing me up like everything
coming out of your mouth I'm [ __ ]
loving no matter I've been following you
for so long and so you know by first
questions a little heady and the second
question is a little bit more practical
the first one is is like you know I've
been putting content out for a while now
and a and I believe that it is in my
best best interest you have everybody
know who I am right like you say and so
I'm trying to capitalize on that
opportunity and the second reason is
like I just really want people to have
that winning mentality because there's
so many people around me that have you
know they're like shitty situations and
it's like the analogy is like a sports
analogies if you're like down all these
points you know your your goalies
injured all these all these excuses
right like I understand it's like you
could fold I understand it's fully
understandable you fold but I just don't
want that for them right like I want
them to win I want them to have that
know that winning mentality that you
have and so but I'm like I lived a
privileged life myself and I'm only like
27 right so I don't feel 100%
comfortable like putting that out like
when I talk to them it goes over well
but but I think you should put out the
content because you come from an
incredible place you you know you are
coming from a privileged place and
you're speaking at it you're gonna be
able to hit people that I'm not able to
hit because they can't associate you're
gonna have more credibility with
somebody who was wildly entitled and
privileged and then you made the move I
talked about making the move because
I've seen it brings so much happiness to
people in that situation you've actually
done it you more legs to stand on
talking about it at some level than I do
or at least from a different perspective
mm-hmm cuz I feel like you don't like
for example there's one guy who's talked
with you I'm glad he's like actually
pretty responsive to you but like you
know he's like divorced and he's like
caught all these others financial
pressure and stuff I'm like dude want
you to just like sell your house and
[ __ ] do that stuff and he responded
really well but I just feel like if I
put content out saying that like who
I've never bought a house you know
anything like I don't know if that's
don't tell people like but bro I never
was a spoiled kid just cuz you weren't
it you know some of the best good some
of the best cook that Bill Belichick was
not a good football player mm-hmm III
don't think that you I think you can
speak to it
from your perspective about it okay I
speak I speak on two core things things
I've lived which is where I really spend
my pocket
but then things that have become very
obvious to me as a human observer I'm
good at that you know I understand that
I feel comfortable with what I'm talking
about I have hundreds and hundreds and
hundreds of thousands of interactions
with human beings that make me very
confident I think you're very confident
in knowing that that person would be
much happier if he minimalized and was
able to breathe and so you think it's
okay to like put content out talking
about as long as you're not full of [ __ ]
I don't think I believe it I don't think
you are I don't think you're gonna make
pretend that you you know like you're
gonna talk and you yeah I think it's
Depp did you try to help hmm okay unique
perspective not only were you privileged
but I assume that also meant that you
were around to other privileged people
and you've seen patterns and and this is
you see it you saw it I was on with
Jared ik little while ago I'm like hey
don't put money on a pedestal oh yeah it
was the ploy
yeah he was all you have to do is just
be humble about it people you know I
talk with such conviction and so Jersey
and so much energy and so much
confidence that people you know often
don't like me at first or think I'm
audacious or think I'm full of [ __ ] or
think that audacious and I understand
when you when you come with this kind of
heat it can come off that way but if you
really watch carefully
what makes me palpable is humility mmhmm
yeah
just be humble about it okay and then
the second question is like you know
like I have all your books right and
crushing it and all that stuff so try to
think of it like brainstorm ways to
maybe make like a little bit more money
like I said I'm living super humbly
right but just to make like maybe five
hundred to like a grand more just do I
want you to make thirty million dollars
a second if you burned it yourself like
let's not demonize money let's just
demonize like being entitled to it or
being subsidized by somebody else cuz it
leads to unhappiness
not because we're jealous of those
people so I think you should because
much money is humanly possible
like let's not demonize it like like if
you earn it that's a great
accomplishment sure for sure but yeah
just just like so I have all these
hobbies right like I'd build model kits
I like do kickboxing like I've been
going off on like all my hobbies and
stuff and like I just thinking like is
there like if I get rainstorm curtain
things you know what listen your your
uncomfortably likable okay so I you're
welcome
so I think you have a real shot what I
would do if I were you based on what I
just heard
if your [ __ ] kickboxer dude and you
got this great hair and you [ __ ] make
models and nerd it out like I think you
need to put your whole [ __ ] world out
there see I'm trying and good so you're
putting out all this stuff you're doing
are you putting up content the model
stuff - oh yeah yeah yeah good so look I
think you keep doing that at volume how
hard are you going at tick-tock no it's
not that much like a little bit a tiny
bit yeah dude I can't even tell you got
some muscles underneath there like dude
do some kickboxing [ __ ] [ __ ] with no
shirt on and you'll [ __ ] like you're
growing a little bit yeah bro you need
to post on kik talk three times a day
okay like if you want a prescription
from the doctor
here you go three times a day tick-tock
three okay and then what do you think
about like if I would is a hobby shop
still like viable City because I don't
own the intellectual property obviously
of the models but of course but you can
make models and sell them you can create
your own bottle like no I don't think a
hobby shop is where you need to go at
this minimal level because retail is not
the place to go especially no I think
he's gonna tip you just watch the girl
three [ __ ] videos ago [ __ ] make
art on jackets and then make one
tick-tock and explode her business true
I think you should make a Shopify store
or or make an Instagram I mean there's a
retro vintage toy guy who just posts his
toys on [ __ ] Instagram and says $13
personal so you know what to do I think
take bro I'm telling you shirtless
kickboxing and [ __ ] and like you know
kid making on tick-tock
will change your life three a day I'm
telling you right now okay telling you
right now I own Jiro I don't when you
tick tock I don't give a [ __ ] about tick
tock line appears tomorrow you know me
you've been around I don't give a [ __ ] I
give a [ __ ] about attention when it's
underpriced that can lead to something
that brings you happiness you know me I
can tell you know me and you are making
three tic TOCs a day [ __ ] that bro I
love everything about you except that
part no 100% I agree I don't like that
part I got to do it what do you like you
guys are sick by the way I watched I
look at his Instagram you're [ __ ]
losers oh man holy [ __ ] no but I just
wanted to say I didn't even know Kurt
was gonna be on today and he never asked
me can I be on the show but I noticed
him following me the other day and I
just like something I saw on his pay I
just like I just liked his page and I
was like because you're both very
handsome Asian man is like are we going
kind of like subculture doesn't super
Sneaky guys I think Dustin's got a
little handsome thing going on like
right now this like cut it you got this
little like [ __ ] like b-boy Biba BMX
[ __ ] going on like this and like I've
I've definitely gained more attraction
towards you during this tea time
thanks right back is the beard anyway
currently if you don't make thank you if
you don't make 3 posts a day I'm done
with you yeah I know for sure I guess
come hang out with you guys
well I could be yeah really work with
work with Dustin you can we can have a
triple date that's awesome thank you so
much Dustin do not let that dude come to
our office unless he's posting three
times a day on tick-tock I will be
creepy and thank you thank you everybody
thank you so much for watching please
sign up for wine text please go to
all-in challenge buy your raffle tickets
my my raffle is expiring scene I'm
really looking forward to spending the
entire year with somebody let's talk
soon I love you guys
see ya I am giving away the ultimate
garyvee experience how should I go okay
over the last week or so I've been a gem
with my friend Michael Rubin and helping
out on this all-in challenge that I am
accepting right now but all-in challenge
calm please go there we are challenging
some of the greatest artists
entertainers athletes in the world to
provide a ridiculous all-time experience
or one of their most iconic items in
their collection to help raise money to
help feed the hungry during this
ridiculous time and so now I have to put
up my auction
so my auction the ultimate Gary the
experience here we go I'm gonna go off
the top of the head they didn't go on
all-in challenge calm to go bid on this
I am giving away okay you get to in the
course of the year you will go garage
sailing with me and film trash talk also
you can get a workout with me and Mike
pecan tea so I know a lot of you pay
attention to that part of my world also
we're gonna go to Wine Library and do a
$25,000 shopping spree that's right I'm
gonna pay my dad well I'm gonna donate
we're gonna pay my dad 25,000 so $25,000
shopping spree at Wine Library I will
walk through the whole store with you
tell you the war stories and you'll buy
a bunch of a wine beer liquor whatever
you want food we are going to go to a
Jets game together
you're gonna tailgate with me I never do
this when I give away Jets tickets I
never let the person sit with me so you
will sit with me during the Jets game I
won't talk to you during the game I'm
completely focused but you'll get that
so the ultimate Jets experience tailgate
full game with me as well also I'm going
to give you one week play at Vayner
media so this is for you and a plus-one
by the way so the two tickets the will
do some plus ones will do some just me
and you depending on what is one full
week at vaynermedia getting consulting
and business advice from team Gary B and
me for the entire week hanging out in
the pit where the shows done you're
gonna be a guest of my podcast we're
going to do a wine dinner for you and
seven of your friends at Hunt fish club
in New York City and I'm gonna fly you
all paid plus 1 to 3 of my keynotes and
we'll work on those details the ultimate
garyvee experience I hope you bid on it
I hope you get involved I hope we raise
a lot of money to help people that need
it all so what's so fun about the Olin
challenge
is you get to challenge people to be in
it I am gonna challenge all the Boehner
sports athletes I expect you in there so
that is number one number two I'm gonna
go with ooh you know what
Tim Berlin the super producer who's
completely lighting up Instagram
Timbaland the super producer I'm calling
you out and finally I got one the
Undertaker one of the great wrestlers of
all time please join the challenge
everybody go to all in challenge calm
please support this the experiences are
gonna be nuts we've been working
bleeding out of the eyeballs for the
last week putting this all together
you're gonna be blown away what you're
about to see on social media hashtag all
and challenge please check it out and
please go to your favorite celebrities
athletes and entertainers and leave
hashtag all-in challenge to get them
involved the all and challenge please
take it